Hi, JSConf!
I am so excited to be here.
I gave a talk last year in the B
track of accessibility of web components.
If you caught that talk, you may
remember a secret thing that happened at the
end which resulted in real life
tacos.
To admit, though, I actually...
I've got to say I like pizza more than
tacos.
If I could choose, I would always choose pizza
every time.
I really
wanted to work pizza into this talk somehow,
and at the risk of sounding
cheesy...
We are going to make this happen.
So hold on a second.
Hi.
I'd like to order a pizza.
Yeah.
Let's do...
One cheese and one pepperoni.
Yeah.
You're going to bring it to Marcy Sutton.
JSConf in track A. Yeah.
You
have 30 minutes.
Thanks.
Bye.
Okay.
So...
Now we can get started.
In the time
it takes for this pizza to get here, I'm going
to tell you about something I'm
really passionate about.
Which is accessibility.
We're going to talk about
automated accessibility testing.
Which is a way that you can actually work
accessibility into your workflow.
I'm Marcy Sutton, I'm a developer in
Seattle.
I currently work at a company called Substantial,
and I want to give
them a shoutout, because I went to Substantial
to learn about git and
pragmatic software practices, and now I'm
giving a talk at JSConf.
So I'm
pretty stoked that I get to work there and
work on this stuff.
In July, I'm
moving to Adobe, so I'm pretty stoked about
that.
I'm an Angular core team
member, I'm devoted to ARIA, the accessibility
module, and since July I've
been working on Angular.
We'll talk a little bit about it, but the
focus today
is obviously automated accessibility testing.
My slides are on Github.
There's
a shortcut for my website, Marcy Sutton.com/JSConf2015.
So accessibility --
the answer to a more inclusive web.
It's the way that we can build websites
and mobile apps and experiences that work
for more people.
Because a fifth of the population on the planet
has some kind of disability.
So if we don't -- if we keep not addressing
accessibility, we're leaving out a
ton of people.
Pizza is also always the answer.
Just saying.
I'm going to
gloss over some accessibility basics, because
we're focusing on something
really technical.
Automated testing.
But you should become familiar with
accessibility basics.
I have them listed in my slides and there's
a link to
more principles if you want to read more.
But some things you should be
considering if you're a web developer are
text alternatives.
Including alt
text for images, form labels, offscreen text
if you have infographics and
things like that, document structure and hierarchy,
which we'll touch on a
little bit today in talking about headings,
HTML semantics, which you should
definitely be using.
Use real buttons and so on.
Keyboard interactivity,
making sure if you're creating custom controls
that they're reachable and
operable from the keyboard and they have adequate
focus styles.
Color contrast.
That's a huge population of people.
As well as keyboard
interactivity.
Not just blind people or people with deafness
or hard of
hearing -- these visual disabilities are a
little more subtle, and they affect
huge populations of people.
So color contrast is in that category.
And visual
contrast in general, which even my slides
-- this projector looks a little
different than my computer screen.
So my slides need adequate contrast.
And
then lastly, if you're building single page
apps or client rendered
applications, you should be familiar with
focus management.
It means that you're guiding the user's keyboard
focus around your apps, so
that if you're opening dialogues or bottom
sheets or other components, that
their focus isn't being dropped.
That you're actually curating their focus
experience so that you can notify them when
things are opening and things are
happening.
And I have some resources at the end if you
want to learn more
about that.
But there was a time when I didn't know accessibility.
Like, you
have to start somewhere.
And so it's important to recognize that you're
not going to be perfect at this
right away.
Jake the Dog from adventure time says -- dude,
sucking at
something is the first step towards becoming
sort of good at something.
And
that's okay.
You know?
It's not something that's going to be perfect
all the
time.
But every little bit of accessibility that
you contribute is so
appreciated and so needed that you can just
learn more as you go.
And it's a
huge win, any time there's something for accessibility
that we're including.
But we're developers.
This is a JavaScript conference.
So we're going to let
the tooling that we're already familiar with
-- using JavaScript task runners
and tools that we love to work with, because
they're technical and geeky -- we
can use this tooling to do some heavy lifting
for us.
Help us identify
accessibility issues in our apps.
The low hanging fruit stuff that you don't
need to pay someone to find, if you can automate
that.
You can free up
people's time to test things that are a little
bit more nuanced and more
subjective.
So we're going to talk about manual testing.
You know, where do I
start when I audit a website for accessibility?
And then we'll move into what I'm calling
sort of automated testing.
Not
looking at the rendered source code, but using
some tools to help you identify
issues.
And then lastly, we'll talk about what you
really came to hear about,
which is definitely automated testing.
And how you can incorporate
accessibility testing -- so, for example,
if you could prevent a broken build
from going out into the wild.
Automating that, so it can withhold a deployment
of some kind.
But the elephant in the room that I have to
mention to you, because we're
talking about automated accessibility testing,
is that it is no substitute for
real user feedback.
Including people with disabilities.
You want to have
people testing your apps so that they can
tell you when something really
sucks.
Like Peter Griffin saying what really grinds
his gears.
Because that
feedback is so valuable.
So that should be part of your strategy as
well.
And
even getting to accessibility earlier in the
design process, too.
Those are
all very important things.
But we're here to talk about automated testing.
Which is an important thing to know how to
do.
So the first thing that I do, when I look
at a website to figure out what the
accessibility situation is -- I just tab through
the page with the keyboard.
So we're going to do that real quick.
I'm going to show you gov.uk, which has
pretty good focus styles, solid blocks of
color, the text links are either
bolded with blue text or bold with white text,
and if we start tabbing through
the page, the focus indicator is really obvious.
It's orange color on whatever
the other background color is.
And it actually really shows you effectively
where you are on a web page.
It has been pointed out to me that this is
technically not WCAG AA compliant.
And that's because there isn't quite enough
visual contrast to meet that
standard.
But what they could do to fix it is either
widen the visual contrast
between the foreground and background colors,
or you could make the text
bigger.
So you have some things that you can do to
fix this.
But compared to
most websites, gov.uk is awesome, and it's
winning the focus style...
Like,
they do it the best of any site I've seen.
So they deserve a pat on the back.
Okay.
So that's the first thing I do.
The next thing I do -- which I'm not
going to spend a whole lot of time on -- but
you should be demoing in screen
readers.
I'm going to show you SoundCloud in Safari
with VoiceOver on the Mac.
But it's not the most used screen reader.
JAWS is the most used.
NVDA and
Firefox are well used.
There's also mobile screen readers.
IOS Safari,
TalkBack with Android is great.
But you should be checking your stuff in a
screen reader so you know what's going on
in your app.
So we're going to
demo...
Oops, wrong window.
So I'm going to hit command F5 and fire up
VoiceOver.
VoiceOver on Safari.
Stream on SoundCloud.
Visit link.
So you see how the SoundCloud link...
It is just a graphic.
There's no text
saying SoundCloud, but when I use the screen
reader, SoundCloud has done a
great job in adding alternative text to their
images.
When I tab through it
with a screen reader, even though it's a graphic
button, I get some text,
because it says SoundCloud on it.
Visiting link.
Link.
Upload.
Banner seven items.
Marcy_SSS pop-up
button.
So this is a pop-up little toggle thing.
If I hit enter, it opens the
pop-up and sends my focus into it.
Now I'm in this list of child links.
You are currently in a list.
Trick with VoiceOver -- mute it.
So we're in this list.
And to get out of
it, I hit escape.
Pop-up button.
Banner seven items.
VoiceOver off.
So that's just a really quick demo with VoiceOver,
to show you what it's
like to use it.
And again, you just turn it on with command
F5 on the Mac, and
you can go check it out.
And I will say Safari works a little better
than
Chrome.
But it's a good thing to do every now and
then.
So that's one of the
first things I do.
Now I want to get into sort of automated testing,
using a
few tools that I think are useful.
Something that you should be checking for
are headings and semantic structure.
So the web was created for documents.
We're creating applications.
It doesn't mean that because you're creating
an
application you get to throw out the semantic
structure and not care about it.
Because a user with a screen reader can use
your heading structure to get an
overall picture of what is on your site.
They can also navigate by headings
and other landmarks.
So this Firefox web developer tool bar I loved,
because
it can show you the heading structure.
So if you install the tool bar, go to
information, and then view document outline,
you can see the heading structure
on your page.
I still use this.
It's probably the only feature in this tool
bar I still use.
But for my Tumblr, accessibility wins, I could
go and look at
it and it'll show you when everything is all
aligned.
So next I want to tell you about the Chrome
accessibility developer tools.
It's a must have for any well developer these
days.
It's great for checking
the overall page accessibility for any website.
Especially in active
development.
It catches kind of the low hanging fruit of
things that you --
like missing labels and things.
So let's go check out an audit.
Okay.
So...
I'm going to pick on CNN today.
Let's go see what crusty accessibility things
they have going on.
So I'm going to open up the dev tools.
And I have the extension installed.
So under audits, I get an accessibility
audit, which I can go and run, and it will
go and it will look at their site,
analyze it, run tests against it, and it will
report back to you what's wrong
with it.
So they are missing a bunch of form labels.
If I drill down into it,
I can look at the specific node that is a
problem.
I can review it in the
elements panel, and go over here in the element
inspector.
You get a couple
little add-ons.
Actually, with the extension, you get this
accessibility
properties panel.
And it will show you some of the accessibility
information.
I'm using Chrome Canary, which actually has
a dev tools experiment.
If you're
curious, I can send you the information later.
Because it's sort of hard to
enable.
But the deal is that this extension will be
moved into the dev tools
at some point.
And Google is working on that right now.
But if you have it
enabled in Chrome Canary, you get this secret
panel of extra information of
the accessibility node.
And this will tell you what role it has, if
it has any
ARIA attributes, and so on.
That highlights an important concept that
I want you to know.
Which is about
the accessibility tree.
The accessibility tree is something created
by
browsers.
It is a parallel structure to the DOM.
And it has in it semantic
information that screen readers and other
assistive technologies can use to
present information without the performance
implications of everything else in
the DOM.
So the accessibility tree you can check a
couple different ways.
If
you go to Chrome://accessibility, you can
look at a raw dump of the
accessibility tree of every tab that you have
open.
Which you can imagine --
it's turned off by default.
Because that would be a pretty big performance
hit.
I have a post in my slides from the Paciello
group with more on the
accessibility tree, including their tool,
called aViewer, which is really
helpful for that.
But when I first got into the Chrome accessibility
developer
tools I found on Github that all the library
code is out there under the
Google Chrome organization on Github, down
to every audit rule as a JavaScript
file.
And I didn't quite know what those were for.
I felt like Finn from Adventure
Time going -- what do you do with those?
Well, that's where we get into
definitely automated testing.
I'm going to start by showing you a tool called
a11y.
It's a numeronym for accessibility.
You take out all the numbers and add
11 in the middle.
You see me tweeting that all the time because
it's shorter.
But they made a really great NPM module.
You can install it with a11y, and you
get this tool where you can call the same
audit that we ran in the browser
from the command line.
So I'm going to show you this.
Instead of pulling it
into a JavaScript file, we're just going to
run it from the command line.
So
I'm going to type a11y cnn.com and then we're
going to wait and hope that it
resolves.
It takes a second.
It's a little bit longer than the browser
extension.
But this is using phantom.js, which is a headless
browser.
So we're
not seeing the browser open.
This is running on the command line, using
phantom, hitting their site, and returning
an audit back to us.
Hopefully this
will work.
Hello, conference Wi-Fi.
So the audit that it gave back to us was
the same audit that we got in the browser
extension, except this is on the
command line.
So I find that this report is a little bit
harder to digest than
the browser extension.
But you can see that it tells you the same
warnings.
It says the controls and
media elements should have labels.
And then it points you to a node in the DOM
tree.
It actually shows you the tree of items, selectors,
that it actually
used to point you to that node in the browser.
So this is pretty cool.
But I'm
not quite sure how I would use this in a project
yet.
I will add that there is
a grunt task for a11y that could be useful.
Ways that you could integrate
automated testing for accessibility.
What if you ran it on every save?
So that you could check whether something
was inaccessible?
It might be a little aggressive.
But you could also run it
on every commit.
Maybe you wanted to check that you had a pre-commit
hook for
git, and you could check whether something
is broken.
More likely, you're
going to run it on a deployment.
If you push out a build that's broken, I'm
either not going to let it go forward or I
can use Travis on Github to say --
hey, the build is broken and that person broke
it.
Which leads us to
protractor, the end to end testing framework
for Angular.
I'm focusing on this
because I worked on it, but the concepts are
similar for any framework.
Protractor is a node module that runs on top
of Selenium web driver.
It fires
up a browser programmatically, you tell it
where to go, and you set up your
website so you can run tests against it and
assert that it's doing the right
thing at the right time.
I wrote an accessibility plug-in for protractor
that
I'll tell you about a little bit.
But protractor would be really useful -- it's
what's called end to end
testing.
It's useful for testing multiple components
on a page together, as
opposed to unit testing, which we'll talk
about in a minute.
But some things
that you could test for include focus management.
Like if you are writing a
single page or client rendered app.
You could check for live updates.
Like,
say your focus is in an input field, and the
act of typing filter something
somewhere else on the screen -- you want to
make sure those components are
working together.
That might be a good thing to test for with
end to end
testing.
Or color contrast.
Maybe you want to check the color contrast
across
your whole app.
You can do that in this as well.
So to get an example, we're going to look
at Angular material start, which I
mentioned I've worked on Angular material,
which is a component library built
on material design -- build on Angular, using
material design.
The Angular
material start is just a small repository
you can grab on Github to get
started.
So I wanted to incorporate the protractor
plugin.
It's pretty simple.
It only has one view.
It has a list of users on the left site nav
and when you
click on one, it opens the specific view in
the primary column on the right.
There's a little share button, and if you
tap that, it will open a bottom
sheet, which is kind of like a dialogue, in
that it opens on top of things.
But it is a sort of drawer that comes up from
the bottom.
It's kind of a
mobile pattern in material design.
The idea with this, though, is that it is
an interim element.
And so when it
opens, for a keyboard user or a screen reader
user, we want to send our focus
there.
Both so that they are alerted to new content,
but also so their focus
is in the general location of this new content.
This would be a perfect thing
to write a test for.
I want to assert that the first button in
the bottom
sheet has focus.
So some setup I had to do for protractor -- the
config file
-- this is in the project now, but I had to
add a line to enable the plugins,
which come with protractor now, that come
with the Chrome accessibility
developer tools.
You just have to enable them in your config.
It also supports
the Tenon API, an accessibility API.
It's super awesome, really robust.
It
requires a subscription and an API key, but
that is worth considering as well.
And the other thing I had to do was add a
selenium address in the config file.
Then in the package.json, under the dev dependencies,
there's something called
scripts, where you can put any arbitrary hook
you want to run from the command
line.
For me to run NPM test, I put a binary from
protractor, which is the
node module we download with it installed,
and then the config.
So once we
have this set up, we can write some tests.
The tests in the project -- I think
they look a little different now, but the
tests for the bottom sheet assumes
that you have already navigated to the page
and that you have already clicked
on one of the avatars on the left.
But this is a jasmine test, so it starts
with a describe statement, just an arbitrary
what we're testing, and then for
each, we have to click on that little share
button to get the bottom sheet
open.
But we're setting up the selenium web driver
to be in the state we want
to test.
So once that happens, we can assert that it
should focus on the first
item.
And this -- there's an infinite number of
ways that you could write a test.
This was the first pass I took at this.
And what I did was I iterated through
the buttons in the bottom sheet, and when
it focuses on one, we have a hold of
the active element.
So I just verify that the one we're iterating
over is the
same one as the active element.
You could do this other ways.
But that was how
I verified that the focus management piece
was working.
So on top of that,
that's a test that I wrote, and that is the
secret to this plugin.
Is that you
have to write tests that hit different parts
of your app, and then the plugin
currently -- it doesn't crawl your whole app.
You have to write some tests,
and then if you have the plugin enabled, like
I showed you in the config, it
will actually run the same audit tools -- or
the audits that we ran in the
browser extension, and Adi's tool.
Same library.
It will run those in your
markup in protractor.
So in material, everything passed.
So I had to make it
fail to show you what a failure looks like.
Ironically, the pass and fail
messages in the command line are in red and
green, which I've heard are a
little hard to see for some people.
So that's a change we have to make.
But it
also says pass and fail in text, so it's not
relying on color alone.
But
that's an improvement I would like to make.
Which I can imagine -- even on a
different monitor would be harder to see.
And quickly mention that Tenon API
would be another option.
If you're interested in that, look at the
protractor
documentation.
But to fix those failures that I made fail
on purpose -- it has
a list of contexts that it iterates over,
and objects, and for each item
there's a button with an icon on it.
I just removed the text from the icon so
it would fail, and to fix it, I just add the
text back in.
Which you can see highlighted.
And then we're going to run it on the command
line and see if it works.
So I have the command line in my slides, and
I'm
just typing NPM test.
That's the hook that we put into package.json.
So I have
selenium web driver running in another tab
in my terminal.
We can see selenium
open up the browser, and now I have to go
back to the slide.
So the difference
between Adi's tool and this one was Adi's
used phantom.
So it didn't open
another browser.
It didn't move our focus away.
With protractor, it's actually
using web driver to fire up a browser.
We specified Chrome in the config, but
you could fire up Firefox, you could run it
in other environments -- but what
that's doing is actually running our tests
against that real browser.
And then
since I fixed the code in the HTML, now it
passes all of the failures that we
had before.
We can also see that there are -- in the actual
material start, there are two
tests.
I only showed you one of them.
But the actual real project, which I'm
running on my computer, that has two tests.
And then we have the plugin
enabled, so on top of our tests, it runs the
Chrome accessibility audit.
It's
pretty awesome.
I'm pretty stoked about that.
So in comparison, unit testing.
And actually, this is something I use more
in my day-to-day work as a
developer.
Unit testing is different in -- different
from end to end testing
in that you need to write tests for individual
components.
Things you could
test are -- ARIA properties that need to change
with user interaction,
keyboard operability, to make sure that tab
index is enabled, and keyboard
commands work.
Text alternatives, making sure, for example,
if you had an icon
button, and you wanted to make sure that it
had a label, or it fell back to a
label or something -- semantics as well.
So unit testing is a really great way
-- if you're not already doing unit testing,
you should be.
That's what I went
to learn at my last job.
But accessibility fits in with that so well,
because
you all of a sudden have test coverage across
your whole app for
accessibility.
So an example that I use a lot is that I am
the primary contributor to NG
ARIA, the accessibility module for Angular.
There are some things I like about
it, some things I want to change, but I have
an example of a custom check box,
a custom element with web components and custom
HTML now.
You can write any
tag name that you want.
So I have sum-check box.
And then using ng model and
ng checked in Angular, I can have it dynamically
add attributes.
So what
ngARIA is doing is ensuring that the ARIA
checked attribute is on the
attribute, as well as the checked attribute.
So if I uncheck the check box, we
see ARIA checked change to false and the HTML5
checked attribute go away.
And
that actually -- checked is what NG checked
is adding.
But because this isn't a real check box, it's
not an input, we need ARIA to
tell the accessibility tree in a screen reader
that it's checked or unchecked.
But the one thing we want to look at here
is that this has tab index.
So NG
model, when it detects a role of check box
-- there are certain scenarios
where it will add tab index dynamically.
And that is what I want to show you
the test for.
I'm refactoring NG ARIA right now, because
it's a bit too
liberal with what it adds.
So I have tests that I'm working on locally
about
which elements it should attach to.
And because Angular has thousands of unit
tests, I usually use -- well, I will isolate
to the NG ARIA tests.
So I
validate that it should not attach to native
controls.
Buttons -- if you put
NG click on a button, it doesn't need tab
index.
It should attach to custom
inputs, and it should attach to elements with
NG click, like divs.
So this is
the stuff that NG ARIA -- the opportunity
we have to improve Angular
applications accessibility.
But we need a little finessing to get this
module
in a better place.
The unit testing is obviously a huge part
of that.
Actually, I'll talk a little bit more about
that, since we have some more time
than I thought we would.
The unit testing -- every time I go to add
a feature
to something like NG ARIA or angular material,
I will start with a test.
Test
driven development -- we're all familiar with
that.
But for accessibility you
can do that.
So when I went to make these changes to NG
ARIA, I would start
with the test.
But it would fail.
It's doing things it shouldn't right now.
So
I start by writing the test and then I go
back to the code and then I make the
changes to get all the tests to pass.
There were actually a lot of features in
NG ARIA, so it wasn't as easy as I thought
it should be.
But that should be
coming up soon.
So today we've talked about keyboard and screen
reader testing as a manual way
to actually check or diagnose the accessibility
of an app.
We looked at sort
of automated tools like the Firefox web developer
tool bar and the Chrome
accessibility developer tools, which the latter
-- the Chrome tool I would
highly recommend using.
Firefox -- the web developer tool bar is cool.
It's a
little bit more dated, and I would say the
heading feature is the only one
that I really use.
But then in automated testing, we talked about
Adi's a11y module and
protractor.
There's other tools out there like Quail and
Tenon and other
things you can use to automate accessibility
testing.
There's more of a
culture.
I'm here talking to you about it at JSConf.
I never thought this
would be a subject you would want to hear
about, but it's changing.
There are
more tools and resources for us as developers
to make the world better, make a
more accessible web.
So it's really exciting to see these things
start to
happen.
In case you're like -- whoa, okay.
I know about automated stuff, but I don't
know anything about accessibility.
I have a ton of resources in my slides,
including people with disabilities user research.
Because that's something we
should be doing.
Conducting user evaluations.
As developers, I always think
it's really cool when I get to go do a different
task than development, like
interviewing users.
I think that's really valuable.
I have a couple blog posts
about auditing a website for accessibility,
a recent one from smashing
magazine on client rendered accessibility.
There's some more tooling on W3C
posts about web accessibility evaluation tools,
the screen reader survey is
the closest thing we have to analytics for
accessibility.
What do people
self-report?
What do they use for browsers and screen readers?
And we can look
at that and look at our own analytics to tell
-- do I really need to support
IE8?
You can go and check.
And then a little bit on what is ARIA, because
I didn't go into that very
much.
So that means that we're at the end.
And there should be something
awesome happening now.
Beyonce dancing, with, like, a pizza coming
out, I
think, is like a win alone.
We're actually done a little bit early.
So I
wanted to say...
In case you don't get a slice of pizza, I
have some pizza
buttons that I would be happy to give to you.
And you can come and find me at
any time, and ask me questions about accessibility.
I'm pretty passionate
about it, obviously.
Our magic thing is not happening.
Oh.
That sucks.
(laughter)
You know, I had a really good run.
Last year was amazing.
And I guess it's
just not happening.
What was supposed to happen was that there
was supposed to
be a pizza that came out.
I actually really want pizza.
I skipped the
afternoon snack.
So it just...
My dreams are foiled.
Your pizza dreams.
As a
consolation prize, I have an inflatable pizza
slice that we can play with in
the pool.
I don't know if you heard about that.
I'm really glad I brought that
now, because I'm so let down that the pizza
didn't show up.
Give them an angry
phone call.
Anyway, thanks for letting me dawdle here
for a minute.
It's been
really fun talking to you.
So thanks!